[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal nous sommes le mercredi 14
décembre voici les titres de l'actualité
locale la droite déjà en marche pour les
échéances électorales à venir
présidentielle et législatives les
réunions entre militants et politiques
s'organisent pour l'alternance eux
s'organisent pour l'innovation les
acteurs économiques du territoire
étaient réunis hier soir à versailles
pour écouter et découvrir des projets
portés par des start up dans le domaine
de l'économie circulaire et dans ce
journal on vous expliquera aussi le
succès d'une exposition qui se tient en
ce moment au japon sur marie antoinette
une exposition à qui bat des records de
fréquentation
la page des primaires enfin tournée
l'heure est à l'union derrière le
candidat françois fillon pour la droite
c'est le message que souhaitez faire
passer hier soir les élus les
républicains de la 11e circonscription
autour de leur candidat désigné pour les
législatives jean michel fourgous le
maire des longs courriers étaient une
cinquantaine de militants de
sympathisants prêt à se lancer dans la
bataille
reportage de wilfrid richy et patrick
jacques de dixmude officiellement ce
n'était pas encore un meeting de
lancement de campagne pour jean michel
fourgous pourtant la nécessité
d'arpenter la 11e circonscription pour
porter la parole de leurs candidats aux
législatives a été largement abordé ce
mardi soir devant les militants les
républicains présents
battu en 2012 par benoît hamon le maire
d'elancourt entend récupérer son mandat
de député en juin et l'issue du scrutin
n'est pas encore écrite pré requis
indispensables à une victoire l'élection
en mai de françois fillon à la
présidentielle fillon a été premier
ministre d'une période difficile
la france le monde a traversé une crise
mondiale très grave il a été il a été
bon donc un disque alliant il a
l'expérience
bon il a été élu largement plus
quelquefois la surprise il faut bien le
dire aujourd'hui militants et
sympathisants sont invités à porter le
projet de françois fillon et à mettre
fin aux polémiques naissantes notamment
autour de la santé il faut simplement
osé mettre ça sur la table sans tabou
on est là pour améliorer les choses pour
que les français aient un système de
protection sociale qu'ils soient
performants qu'ils soient bien sûr qui
concerne tout le monde et en même temps
qu'ils soient financés le lancement
officiel de la campagne des législatives
côté républicain devrait intervenir fin
janvier dans la 11e on espère bien
mettre l'accent sur l'emploi ça dans les
quartiers on sent que c'est une vraie
attente on a beaucoup d'énergie des des
jeunes notamment qui veulent s'investir
qui veulent créer qui veulent innover
qu'ils sentent que l'économie est
totalement verrouillé sur les sept
communes de la 11e circonscription cinq
sont actuellement dirigées par la droite
mais la gauche que ton visage et
résister avec la commune de trappes où
siège d'ailleurs un certain benoît en
politique toujours plusieurs élus de
gauche ont décidé de parrainer une
cinquantaine de lycéens sans papiers
basée dans l'île de france ses
parrainages doivent permettre d'appuyer
les démarches de ces jeunes et de leur
famille pour obtenir ensuite un titre de
séjour auprès de la préfecture
six élus yvelinois sont notamment
concernés c'est le cas de benoît hamon
et sandrine legrand gang élus
socialistes du territoire favoriser l
innovation et les rencontres entre les
différents acteurs du monde économique
c'était l'objectif de la soirée happy
nwe organisée hier soir à versailles par
le réseau open i9 de la chambre de
commerce et de l'industrie du
département pour cette soirée est dédiée
à l'économie circulaire 5 start
présenter leur projet devant une
centaine de personnes
reportage vingt candidats et seulement
cinq finalistes les startups
francilienne présente ce mardi 13
décembre au café théâtre de la royale
factory avec quelques minutes seulement
pour présenter plusieurs années de
travail
parmi les concurrents du soir squeeze
une entreprise yvelinoise qui conçoit et
commercialise une go
réutilisable pour la famille on
souhaitait quand même j'irai arriver à
une une solution beaucoup plus
responsable beaucoup plus respectueuse
de l'environnement et qui aussi avait un
coût beaucoup plus limité parce que mine
de rien le budget gourde à usage unique
est quand même très élevé lorsqu'on a
pas mal d'enfants pour écouter
départager les orateurs innovants plus
d'une centaine de potentiels
investisseurs et décideurs économiques
étaient présents dans la salle
versaillaise il faut que les gens se
rencontrent se révèle et open line up
est un véritable révélateur d'un côté
c'est à dire qu'on met en avant met en
lumière des compétences et des talents
sur le territoire dont des start up
innovantes mais çà çà çà suffit pas il
faut aussi connecter les gens et on se
présente avec open enough commun un
connecteur de compétences prix du jury
de cette soirée dédiée à l'économie
circulaire la boîte à champignons une
entreprise basée dans les yvelines qui
permet grâce à un simple processus
écologiques de produire soi-même ses
champignons
c'est une reconnaissance et un
encouragement à continuer c'est un
encouragement à avancer toujours dans le
même sens et à être fidèle à ce qu'on a
pensé au début à a pas pervertir le
projet à part le travestir pour le
faire baisser le niveau on doit
continuer à ne voir ce niveau d'exigence
et a pris comme celui là bas nous
encourageons sens là également lauréat
du prix public phoenix propose une
gestion éco-responsable des invendus des
entreprises culture à présent avec marie
antoinette un personnage ô combien
marquants de l'histoire française elle
qui a été à rennes sous la révolution
française et depuis la sortie du film
marie antoinette de sofia coppola en
2006 son histoire est très apprécié à
l'étranger notamment du côté du japon
pour preuve une exposition a lieu en ce
moment même aux morilles hats senteurs
galerie à tokyo mélanie poquet bonsoir
vous êtes avec nous pour nous parler de
cet engouement japonais ont sans nicolas
en effet marie antoinette une reine à
versailles c'est le nom de l'exposition
elle a débuté le 25 octobre dernier et
plus 250 oeuvres issues des collections
du château et de prêts publics et privés
sont actuellement là bas l'exposition
est né d'une demande de la chaîne
japonaise ltv on le voit à l'image des
salles ont été totalement recréer sur
place celle de son petit appartement qui
se trouve au rez-de-chaussée au
rez-de-chaussée du château la
bibliothèque qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui a été reconstruite en 3d
c'est aussi le cas de la pièce des
banques ne se découvre habituellement
que l'on de visites thématiques bertrand
rondeau et l'un des commissaires de
cette exposition on les écoute
l'explosion a été pensé comme une
biographie la reine donc un parcours qui
évoque sa vie de sa naissance à vienne
jusqu'à sa mort le 16 octobre 1793
pendant la
les poc de la terreur et pour pouvoir
développer cette biographie nous avons
voulu avoir la foi des portraits des
images des représentations de son cercle
de sa famille
et puis aussi des objets qui évoque sa
vie qui évoque son entourage évoque son
goût et mélanie on lisait l'exposition
bat des records de fréquentation
en fait chaque jour l'exposition
accueille plus de 2700 visiteurs au
début du mois de décembre
un peu plus d'un mois après son
ouverture plus de
cent mille visiteurs s'étaient déjà
plongé dans l'histoire de marie
antoinette et l'exposition est prévu
jusqu'au 2 février 2017 ce qui laisse
savoir des chiffres intéressants
alors expliquez nous comment on peut
justement expliquer cet engouement
autour de marie antoinette au japon bah
c'est tout simplement la faute
je serais si on peut utiliser ce mot
d'un manga la rose de versailles riyoko
ikeda une mangaka japonaise le publié en
1973 elle s'intéresse au mariage de la
jeune marie antoinette en 1770 avec le
futur louis saez dans l'ouvragé se
concentre sur l'amour que la jeune reine
aurait eu avec un gentilhomme suédois
axel de fersen essentiellement son
histoire tragique son destin tragique et
cette vie qui est un véritable roman et
aucun romancier n'aurait pu écrire de
lui même et là je pense que ça fascine
ça fascine bien sûr delà du japon mais
particulièrement au japon par cet aspect
tragique et caractéristiques aussi du
roman c'est le l'analyse de
de l'avis de marionnettes au sein de la
famille royale au sein de son couple
avec éventuellement fersen le paysage le
personnage de faire ce n est salée on
sent que les japonais sont très attirés
par cette partie romance et mélanie vous
l'avez emmener avec vous un deuxième
manga est sorti sur marie antoinette la
jeunesse d'une reine on le voit alors
elle entraîna tout à fait ça celui ci
l'a été créée par contre pas refus du
mystérieux en collaboration cette fois
que les professionnels du château
contrairement aux premiers qui laissait
apparaître une marie antoinette
romantique celui ci donne des
informations plus réel plus historique
est faux de dire avec l'exposition les
membres du château veulent replacer
marie-antoinette dans l'histoire
française
et c'est aussi un moyen de séduire le
public japonais
parce qu'avec les événements de 2015 le
château a vu sa fréquentation de
visiteurs étrangers baisser de près de
14% sur le premier semestre 2007
merci mais la nuit pour toutes ces
précisions en sport des collégiens ont
découvert ce matin la piste du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
l'événement était organisé dans le cadre
des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire durant la visite les
élèves ont pu également poser des
questions à l'équipe de france de piste
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
mélanie poker c'est assez compliqué au
début pour apprendre pour freiner parce
qu'il faut freiner avec les pieds au
mieux qu'avec les mains hermès 13 ans
adepte du vtt a pu tester pour la
première fois la piste du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il était accompagné de sa classe de 4e
du collège de la couldre de montigny le
bretonneux
cette session était organisée ce
mercredi 14 décembre dans le cadre des
deux pays
les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire
l'idée c'est de pouvoir justement
répondre cette action donc à l'ensemble
des institutions scolaires de la région
ile de france est donc là on poursuit
justement la série de d'opération avec
avec les collèges donc ce n'est pas la
première aujourd'hui ça sera pas la
dernière non plus après un baptême d'une
heure les 30 élèves avaient le sourire
c'était très bien même si j'ai vu
quelques chutes qui m'a pas perturbé
mais sinon ça rester cool la matinée
s'est ensuite poursuivie par un
entraînement de l'équipe de france à la
fin de la session
les collégiens ont pu poser des
questions aux pistards bah ouais ça
vraiment sympa de pouvoir partager notre
passion avec avec ces collégiens la
piste c'est pas très connu du coup bah
ça me fait plaisir de leur faire
connaître un peu ce monde ce parti-là du
vélo qui n'est pas connu du tout je me
dis qu'ils sont hyper paresseux des
professionnels y roulent hyper vite et
tout un paravent à ce que j'ai fait moi
je me dis que c'est vraiment incroyable
ce qu'ils font et où au total près de
300 jeunes ont participé à ces deux pays
au vélodrome depuis deux ans de
nouvelles sessions avec les collégiens
devraient être organisées au premier
trimestre 2010 7 j - 10 avant noël il
est donc grand temps de décorer sa
maison pour accueillir dignement le père
noël à guyancourt l'espace yves montand
propose des ateliers pour apprendre par
exemple à faire un mémo nous avons
assisté à l'une de ces séances les
détails avec camille lambert
alors voilà ce que nous va faire un mémo
avec de la décoration noël donc pour
faire votre mémo prenez d'abord une
planche de bois et recouvrez la de
peinture disposer ensuite vos
décorations selon vos envies
un atelier de noël pour petits et grands
sous la direction de florence coquard
ces ateliers sont destinés pour les
parents et les enfants
d'accord on accepte les enfants
accompagnés d'un parent dont quatre
sites sable tous
alors on prend pas des tout petits tout
petit apport pour tout ce qui est mémo
au niveau de la décoration ce qui leur
permet aussi de pouvoir coller peindre
voilà est vraiment personnalisée selon
leurs goûts une recette qui a déjà fait
des adeptes c'est la deuxième fois que
sabine participent aux ateliers de
l'espace yves montand et une quinzaine
de jours on a fait le calendrier de
l'avent et ma fille a adoré et il ya
aujourd'hui décide j'ai décidé de
participer à cet atelier pour lui faire
le mémo on est vraiment là dedans on
pense pas autre chose et ça déstresse en
même temps j'ai reposant calme puis on
apprend des nouvelles techniques
voilà ça ça fait travailler un petit peu
aussi l'imaginaire un atelier programmé
samedi 17 décembre comptait 1 euro 50
l'inscription florence vous apprendra
même a créé la botte du père noël seule
limite la créativité fin de ce set 8
journal rendez vous demain pour une
nouvelle édition tous les replays
tous les replays excusez-moi de nos
reportages sont à retrouver sur notre
site internet
en attendant les programmes se
poursuivre sur notre en scène bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]